I'm not afraid of intimacy are you crazy
how can I be afraid of intimacy when the
internet calls me the Taylor Swift of
YouTube um I'd like to be excluded from
this thread shut up but in working with
the dating coach I know I know it sounds
extra spark but it's been really helpful
so just to spend your judgement I've
found that most of her principles
actually deal with the self so though
you'd think a dating coach is someone
who would help you answer texts or work
on her online dating profile she mostly
focuses on all of your and
emphasizes working on yourself to accept
love from someone else hey you're great
like you I look
I love you okay bye and when the issue
of intimacy initially came up I almost
laughed it was like oh no intimacy is
something I deeply crave trust me I have
no commitment issues and then she was
like oh really well do any of these
sound like you dismissing someone on the
first date because of no chemistry
sleeping with someone too soon
feeling bored when the other person does
everything right being nitpicky about
small things feeling intensely about the
other person right away and therefore
projecting onto them and choosing
unavailable men ah you know maybe maybe
like one of those and these specific
symptoms of being afraid of intimacy
usually stems from you guys did children
a lack of self-worth when someone is
treating us nicely and things are going
well to the person with no self-worth
it feels unfamiliar and strange pain is
what we know abandonment is what we know
long and tension anxiety those are all
of our feelings associated with love not
things being easy flowing and joyful no
I'm not suffering I'm clearly not in
love and if you like me felt personally
attacked by these six signs know that
love does not feel like we think it
should because our associations are
wrong the beginning shouldn't be intense
that is a red flag that we're buying
into our idea of a person and not who
they actually are chemistry can develop
as you get to know them and dismissing
them off the bat disallows that it takes
a while to get to know a person and
those nitpicky things that annoy you now
may be overshadowed by the amazing
qualities the person has to offer and
sleeping with someone releases the
chemical in women to him
a bond so if you do that before you
really know a person you shouldn't be
surprised when you wake up and discover
you're in love with a narcissist you
know the photo honestly I was really
surprised that I have fears of intimacy
I mean given my history of being like a
serial monogamist
I would have guessed that my problems
were probably from a lack of self-worth
but surprise I am afraid of intimacy and
I have problems with self-worth yes
children yes I have the best of both
worlds baby but the good news is that
once you're self-aware like most things
you can actively begin combating these
fears if intimacy in a real relationship
are what you really want then you can
start taking note of all of your actions
and your patterns and ask yourself am i
making these decisions because the other
person genuinely isn't right for me or
am I afraid of developing an authentic
connection with this human being
so stop sabotaging your love life
because as much as we think we don't
deserve love we do keep working on it
I'm Anna Akana and I I'm Anna Akana
and I love hello I love myself okay bye
thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring
today's video Squarespace has beautiful
award-winning templates and an
all-in-one platform so there's no need
to install patches or upgrades ever they
have 24-hour customer service for all
yours an emotional support mean and a
simple and unique domain set of
experience with Squarespace you can
create any kind of website whether
you're afraid of intimacy afraid of
abandonment or just afraid of the
intricacies of a meaningful human
relationship but a squarespace.com /
Anna to start your free trial today and
use the offer code and after 10% off at
checkout